Tucker Carlson's first episode of Tucker
on Twitter Nets it says 70 million but
that's June 7th I think it's at 110
million right now if not higher Tucker
is on fire
to uh say the least he's absolutely
crushing it with where he's at
the first episode uh okay tour the CEO
Elon Musk acknowledge his High View
count but clarified that it only counts
for views on the X Twitter app or web
browser excluding views from other
sources like Google search results or
Bloomberg terminals Carlson chose tutor
as a platform for his show after leaving
Fox News citing the platform's
commitment to free speech he expresses
hope that Twitter would provide a
platform with without Gatekeepers
emphasizing his gratitude for the
opportunity to be on the platform but
very quickly by the way second episode
came out yesterday which has got
somewhere around 40 million views
and then immediately after his first
episode FOX News tells Tucker Carlson he
violated his contract with new Twitter
show this is NBC News uh Fox News
informed Tucker Carlson is a lawyer that
he violated his contract with the
network by releasing the first episode
of his new show on Twitter the breach of
contracts stated in a letter from Fox
News General counselor Brandon Googer
who referred to Carlson's contract
signed in November of 2019 and amended
in February of 2021 Carlson's lawyer
Brian Friedman argued that any legal
action taken by Fox News would infringe
on Carlson's First Amendment rights
Carlson's new show on Twitter titled
episode one featured his unfounded claim
that Ukraine was responsible for an
attack on a dam in Russia Russian
occupied territory leading to
devastating floods Ukrainian president
zielinski and U.S officials have accused
Russia of the attack while Russia denies
any involvement I mean that's pretty and
and yesterday he's out there doing what
he's doing yesterday if you watch what
he said yesterday Twitter a lot of
people on Twitter are going back and
forth saying what what is this guy
saying is he trying to say something
because a part of what he said in
episode number two I think 90 seconds
into it or two minutes into it he says
by 2008 no one questioned that Barack
Obama had a highly creepy personal life
what what what creepy what a highly
creepy personal life is he talking about
like Tom what do you think about what's
going on here right now with Fox News uh
suing uh Tucker or getting after him I
love this so let's go to one sentence
that everyone will understand said Fox
sends a letter that said Mr Carlson
Services shall be completely exclusive
to Fox that was under a contract with
fox fox pays Carlson specifically to be
there
now then he goes on Twitter Twitter's an
open platform and he put a video up on
Twitter showing what he thinks that's it
does he have a contract with Twitter No
Elon Musk has said so there's no
contract with this guy is my fake Elon
Musk went out of his way to put a tweet
out remember that said there is no
contract with Tucker Carlson so he went
out and did that this would be
this is going to be tough for the fox
lawyer to get a judge to injunct and say
oh yeah well you've got a contract with
Fox your servicers are exclusive of the
fox and now you're providing Services
he's going to have to Fox has got to
successfully argue that he's providing
services to Twitter he's not he's a free
guy stating what he believes and put a
video up on a open social media platform
I I don't think fox has an angle here
because what judge is going to say that
how is he monetizing his content on
Twitter that's exactly right what's the
contract or do you get casual
monetization for cumulative views does
he I I don't know I mean does that work
that's a good question if he doesn't
then there's no commercial relationship
even just a casual commercial
relationship or you click the button
saying yeah send me a check if there's
enough views and you can sell ads
against it but that still isn't a
contract to provide services I I think
he's in the clear I think he knows he's
in the clear and I think that this is
the only angle that fox can take but
they got to find a judge that will
injunct and say this yeah musk made it
clear that he's not paying him he says I
also want to be clear that we have not
signed a deal of any kind whatsoever
Tucker is subject to the same rules and
rewards of all content creators rewards
means subscriptions and advertising
Revenue share coming soon which is a
function of how many people subscribe
and the advertising views associated
with the content I hope that many others
particularly from the left also choose
to be content creators on this platform
things like the test run patent guess
what he'll do this bro think about how
brilliant this is for one year he's
going to do this and get numbers at him
like 75 million 75 80 million 100
million once Fox lets them go then
they're going to say okay now it's time
to start paying this dude he's gonna get
he's confusing the entire cable news
lineup combined combined exactly so
that's a great move bro get your name up
there and then absolutely crushing it
killing it bro the guy has a very
necessary voice clearly the market wants
to hear what he has to say yeah I I
personally think that he's
the Top If not one of the top opinion
personalities out there I don't consider
him a little journalist meaning
he'll say he's admitted sometimes I'll
say things that aren't right and wrong
and he's not looking to get fact checked
these days but when it comes to his
opinion people do what here want to hear
what he has I love that you said Adam
it's opinion do you know the girl the
executive she's the producer uh Caroline
that was on the flight that's your new
girlfriend she's gorgeous no she's
married with kids but anyway we'll get
into that later uh she's instead of her
stuff shut up never listen we had a
conversation where we were saying it's
like your opinion right Tom we are not
even allowed to have an opinion about
what's going on everything that we talk
about is in factual I'm not getting fact
checkered I'm not saying Hey listen this
is a fact I have an opinion he has an
opinion like the north stream pipeline
right like in my opinion why would one
side do it it's pretty much going to be
the other side and that's my opinion I
think they have to try to shut your ass
up if you have an opinion that goes
against their narrative so that's what
thanks for your opinion Ben you're
welcome free
unedited unadulterated so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
thank you